ich habe verkackt hallo mein name ist
luca meine lieben zuschauer ich habe
bereits vor einiger zeit eine trainer
challandes hochgeladen wein weil du ja
ich war den tränen wirklich sehr nahe
allerdings habe ich es geschafft nicht
zu heiße steht wieder
ich habe in meiner reaktion auf jeden
fall nicht geweint und ganz ganz viele
leute meinten hey luca macht dann
nochmal einen zweiten teil
und ich würde sagen wir fangen direkt
mit der ersten animationen die erste
animation hier ist ziemlich kurz und
zwar geht die 07 30 sekunden
wir sehen hier einen jungen der noch zu
hause wohnt und ja
also ich glaube ich weiß worum es geht
er läuft hier zum schulbus
nun ist er in der schule angekommen und
bis jetzt wieder zu hause wird wieder
von seinem vater er ist auf jeden fall
wieder zu hause angekommen setzt seine
maske ab und unter der maske sieht man
halt das wie gesagt das war ein ganz
ganz kurze animation aber glaube ich
nach animationen die sehr viel bewegen
kann ich weiß nicht ob das gerade sinn
ergibt was ich jetzt sage aber ich finde
dass eltern in einer gewissen form
eigentlich so eine lizenz haben sollten
kinder wirklich bekommen zu dürfen es
gibt einfach so viele kinder die in
haushalten aufwachsen in denen einfach
die eltern kriminell sind oder zumindest
ein elternteil und die einfach sonne
ich glaube ihr wisst was ich meine hab
ich auch übrigens wieder alle links zu
den animationen auf die wir heute noch
reagieren werden unten in die video
beschreibung gepackt also checkt die
gern aus und auch noch weitere
informationen zu den kampagnen für die
diese sachen gemacht wurden machen
allerdings direkt weiter mit der zweiten
animation die ich uns heute raus gesucht
habe und zwar heißt die safe place es
geht los in einem kinderzimmer so sieht
zumindest aus also hier sind lego steine
hier sind playmobil-figuren das hier ist
glaube ich ein pirat
nun sehen wir dass hier ein junge mit
seinen spielzeugen rumspielt er da noch
eine superman figur und schmeißt den
piraten einfach an die wand
geht
jetzt darum dass spielzeuge beschädigt
werden also bisher weiß ich noch nicht
ganz genau um was es hier wirklich geht
er hat noch sein so jetzt passiert
irgendwas als ich vor zwei drei wochen
schon mal eine trainer challandes ihr
auf meinem kanal hochgeladen habe waren
die animationen er so ein tier was dann
irgendwie seine mutter verliert durch
wilderer oder einer anderen animation
ging es dann beispielsweise darum dass
ein kleiner hund seinen ersten tag an
einer hundeschule hatte und weil er zu
klein war dann irgendwann
rausgeschmissen wurde die animation auf
die wir heute reagieren sind allerdings
auf kinder getrimmt glaube ich so ein
bisschen ich glaube dass auch diese
animation hier wieder irgendwas mit
gewalt zu tun hat allerdings schauen wir
erstmal weiter und zwar kommt der vater
halt nach hause der junge schaut aus
seinem zimmer raus hat glaube ich schon
angst vor seinem vater und seinen vater
alkohol verändert menschen echt so krass
es geht hier mittlerweile so weit dass
der junge schon seine tür
verbarrikadiert mit irgendwelchen
gegenständen die er hat der mann bittet
er seinen vater sieht nun die tür und
wird jetzt ja
ich weiß dass das
video hier eine trainer challenges und
eventuell erwarten einige hey es soll
irgendwie traurige tier animationen
geben und blabla aber dass hier gerade
so alkoholsucht im familienumfeld ist
halt ein thema was wirklich wichtig ist
wir schauen uns das erst mal zu ende an
leichtem das ganze ja noch ein gutes
ende
wie ich ja der vater der hat aber schon
seinen gürtel rausgeholt
der kleine junge versteckt sich in
seinem schrank und hat zu recht auch
angst vor seinem vater der jetzt total
betrunken
ich weiß einige werden sich beschwert
zwischendurch stoppe wenn ihr das
komplett ohne kat sehen wollt dann
schaut euch nicht mein video an sondern
klickt unten in der beschreibung auf den
link von der animation da könnt ihr euch
ja komplett ohne karte anschauen aber
ich muss bei sowas zwischendurch stoppen
und aber wir schauen jetzt erstmal der
junge sitzt auf jeden fall immer noch in
seinem schrank hier vorne
der vater macht jetzt den schrank auf
und das war's das war okay
es hat so ein bisschen so ein offenes
ende und man kann sich jetzt denken wie
es vielleicht endet ich finde sowas geht
mir unter die haut als jetzt irgendwie
ein tier wo ja wir aber wir schauen uns
mal die nächste animation erstmal an wer
live auf der also auf deutsch übersetzt
das leben des todes let's go wir sehen
hier einen vogel der glaube ich tot ist
hier ist ein fuchs und im hintergrund
sieht man das irgendwie so herumgelaufen
ist da geht auch die hand auf den fuchs
der liegt jetzt auch tod rum wir sind
immer noch in dem wald da fliegt immer
noch schonach
ach so das war keine handvoll menschen
irgendwie so von wegen haye
alles wird gut blabla sondern das war
der tod der die hand darauf gelegt hat
ja nicht dumm dass ich jetzt erst noch
eine halbe minute gecheckt hat hier ist
ein kleiner hase der auch so verdutzt
schaut er frisst ein bisschen gras und
ja man sieht schon mehr schatten wird
größer da kommen wieder die hand und der
hase steht also das ist auch wieder das
ist der tod
okay der tod wird symbolisiert durch
diese personifizierte personifizierte
person der tod fliegt weiter durch den
wald schaut sich um entdeckt jetzt
wahrscheinlich ein neues opfer ja genau
er sieht irgendwie ein reh was da das
gras frisst und der tod denkt sich jetzt
auch da wahrscheinlich wieder hellwege
ich meine hand drauf und dann ist das
leben von re beendet er nähert sich ang
mit seiner hand das liegt aber um sich
und entdeckt den tod
spitz die lauscher die ohren dass gott
interessant was passiert
[Musik]
das reh ist dem tod entkommen der tod
fliegt dem reh hinterher das reh hoppelt
weg und geht zu ihren
ach das ist der moment in dem film wenn
der bösewicht merkt dass er halt nen
scheiß bösewicht ist der tod hat hier
gerade einfach die pflanze getötet und
ist jetzt ein bisschen traurig und
bedrückt darüber glaube ich ich glaube
jetzt ist die zeit gekommen wo der tod
mehr oder weniger merkt dass er leute
nicht umbringen soll als ich meinen der
tod ist ja unvermeidlich so jeder stirbt
irgendwann mal allerdings bin ich
gespannt was jetzt passiert und zwar der
tod nähert sich dem reh und er hätten
nun die möglichkeit das reh zu töten
ich bin ich bin ehrlich gesagt ich bin
ziemlich locker er legt sich daneben
ok damit hätte ich jetzt gar nicht
gerechnet dieser moment wenn du ganz
normal geschützt und dann legt sich der
tod
neben dich wer kennt nicht ich bin auf
jeden fall gespannt wie es jetzt weiter
geht der nächste morgen die rehe laufen
durch den wald den tod acht der vierte
daher auch und jetzt auch jetzt
sind die da abf auf lebenszeit oder was
ich kann mir ein bisschen vorstellen was
der hintergedanke bei
das macht meine komplette vorstellung
gleich wieder kaputt ich habe jetzt ein
bisschen gedacht dass der hintergedanke
diese animation ist einfach dass man mit
dem tod leben sollte das was ich schon
gesagt habe hey man kann die toten nicht
vermeiden
der tod trifft irgendwann jeden mal
machen wenn man sollte einfach damit
leben
man sollte keine angst vor dem tod haben
sondern einfach wissen hey wenn es
soweit ist dann ist es soweit dann kann
man da nichts gegen machen die zeit
vergeht auf jeden fall es ist wieder
abend der tod wieder mit dem reh
es ist mittlerweile schon winter also
der sommer ist vorbei beiden laufen zu
den anderen tieren und sind jetzt
irgendwie allerbeste freunde
man sieht schon jetzt hier dass der
schnee wahrscheinlich mehr oder weniger
auftauen wird jetzt ist sogar sommer
schon wieder und das reh ist online
die anderen hoppeln weg um das hier ist
richtig schlapp auf den beinen und kann
nicht mehr richtig los laufen
es hält auch schon so ein bisschen und
schaut sich jetzt um zu seinem freund
sage ich mal dem tod und läuft jetzt auf
den tod und leben gerungen das reh läuft
auf den tod zu aber der tod weigert sich
und möchte dass sie noch nicht umbringen
es schließt jetzt allerdings die augen
und berührt von sich aus
[Musik]
ich
also
ich hab' ich habe
heule allein wenn man sie dieses bild
anschauen der tod um abend nun das reh
und das reh sagt in sich zusammen und
das geht dann genau in die richtung was
ich mir schon gedacht habe was ein
bisschen die moral von der geschicht
sein soll und zwar dass man ja eh gegen
den tod nichts machen kann und
irgendwann ist es halt so weit
scheiße alter
ich bin innerlich grad richtig aufgelöst
an der stelle durch das heutige video
jetzt allerdings auch beenden meine
lieben freunde ganz ganz viele von euch
meinten unter meiner ersten trailer
challenger luca macht er noch mal eine
zweite mit anderen animationen und heute
ich hab's ich habe es nicht geschafft
diese live auf des animation jetzt
gerade am ende die war
die war zu krass für mich auf jeden fall
und schreibt mir gerne in die kommentare
ob ich hier von auch noch einen dritten
teil machen soll also noch eine trainer
challandes hat einen daumen hoch da wenn
euch das video gefallen hat und jetzt
kommt das aus rom
[Musik]
zum 1